on that topic sort of a little bit of a
tangent there's a lot of folks in the in
the in the left community
uh far left Community socialist
community that I think are at the source
of a kind of derision towards the b word
the billionaires
does it bother you or do you think
that's in part Justified a kind of uh
using the word billionaire as a dirty
word I think it's perfectly Justified
and that it's a populist shorthand right
um so obviously when I talk about
inequality I often talk about power
dynamics right between workers and
bosses and and so on billionaire is just
the 99 one percent version of it it's
just a popular shorthand to just explain
the fact that you know there's
um a lot of people who have accumulated
obscene
wealth
um these people aren't in my mind
parasites you know in the in the kind of
very very old school
um socialist rhetoric in that
of course
um capitalists
um provide employment take entrepreneur
with come up with new ideas sometimes
themselves so sometimes directly manage
uh work and whatever whatever else
um but they exert so much power over the
lives of not just their workers but
society as a whole uh taking away some
of their wealth and power is a way to
just Empower others
um and again these things have policy
trade-offs if you if you just snap your
fingers and say
um Elon Musk you're now
um all your wealth is gone you're now
you know on food stamps or whatever else
and that kind of arbitrary way you'd be
a total totally disincentivized people
from trusting the rules of the game as
they've been set up in a capital society
and I think that would have negative
consequences for workers but saying that
hey this person has too much power and
too much wealth and has too much ability
to dictate things about the lives of of
others I think it's just simply a fact
and
um I think it's true in the cases of
people who are good people and and have
risen to this position and as sure in
the cases of people who are maybe not so
good people and who have reason to these
these positions so I agree with you in
part but I have to push back here so one
of the problems I see is using
billionaires as shorthand to talk about
power inequality and wealth and
inequality
often dismisses the fact that some of
these folks
are some of the best members of our
society so outside of the the however
the system has created inequalities
a young person today
should dream to build cool stuff not for
the wealth not for the power the fame
but to be part of building cool stuff
now there's a lot of examples of
billionaires that have gotten there in
Shady ways and so on
and you can point that out but in the
same way we celebrate great artists and
great athletes and great uh literary
icons and sort of writers and Poets and
musicians and engineers and scientists
we should celebrate we should sort of
separate
the the human Creator from the wealth
that the system has given them that that
that's what I worry about is like
in our system some of the greatest
humans are the ones that have become
rich and so we sometimes mix up the if
you want to criticize the wealth
sometimes criticize the human and the
Creator while that should actually be
the person we aspire to be
so you know I would agree with that
um LeBron James if he's not already in
his lifetime will be a billionaire
um and he got his money largely through
just being an incredible athlete
excelling in his field more than
anyone's you know besides for Michael
Jordan I think he's my number two he
might be my number one
um yeah I'm willing to keep keep an open
mind about the LeBron versus Jordan
conversation but
um
you know he got that through his Merit
and he's been rewarded in a party's
getting rewarded because he's created
vast amounts of Wealth Beyond what he's
getting this is just his share you know
it's a salary cap League uh whenever
he's doing an endorsement obviously that
company is thinking that he's worth more
than what they're paying him for that
that endorsement and so on and to the
extent with um Elon Musk people see
Innovation and they see someone who
will put himself out there with
sometimes crazy ideas because he's
trying to think about the future and
trying to just
push things forward instead of just
sitting on whatever money he has now and
just investing it earning you know six
percent you know for the return for the
rest of his life you know I think that
that's that's a positive thing uh but I
think it it doesn't get to the broader
policy question when people invoke
billionaires they're invoking the
Specter of inequality and power
um it
it's not normally the rhetoric that I
use because I propose opposed and I use
more traditional
um socialist rhetoric and and terms but
I think it gets at something real so
often with these sorts of shorthands we
use in politics
um there are
um
you know they're imperfect but they
speak to to a real a real thing and they
they feed a little bit of fun that folks
like AOC and Elon have with each other
creates it it feeds it inspires it
serves as a catalyst for uh productive
discourse